[Par télépathie] Bonjour c'est Cyprien !
Ouais j'ai réussi !
Hier soir pendant mon cours privée de caring sur gazon, j'ai essayer de pensée à la chose la plus absurde de la planete terre.
Et j'ai trouvé de que c'est...c'est les jeux vidéos !
Si vous êtes pas d'accord avec moi, pensez juste à une seule chose : Quel est le jeu le plus vendu de tous les temps ?
C'est le jeu le plus bizarre du monde !
Ok les mecs j'ai un concept là, alors le jeu ça va être un plombier avec une moustache qui doit sauver une princesse, quand il mange un champignon il grandit, il peut monter sur des tortues, il peut monter sur le dos d'un...d'un dinosaure. Et ça sera le jeu le plus vendu de tout les temps !
A oui et comme on est une entreprise japonaise, on va lui donner un nom italien. Qui me suit ?
D'ailleurs il y a u ntruc absolument iréaliste dans les jeux vidéos, c'est la jauge de vie !
Non ça n'existe pas hein, t'as pas une jauge de vie comme ça à coté de ta gueule mais y a ça presque dans tous les jeux vidéos !
Tu peux te prendre une balle dans l'épaule comme ça, une balle dans la tête, une balle dans le ventre, mais t'est toujours vivant puisque qu'il te reste de la jauge de vie.
Par contre tu te tors la cheville et là oh tu meurs ! Ohhhhh...ma cheville oh !
Non tu te prend une balle, tu meurs comme une merde ! C'est ça, ça c'est la réalité.
Bon c'est vrai que sans jauge de vie, les jeux vidéos ça serais un p'tit peu chiant...
Jeu vidéo : <<Nouvelle partie !>>
*BANG !*
Jeu vidéo : <<Jeu terminée !>>
J'ai payé ce jeu 70€ !!
Ensuite en terme d'absurdité, t'as des genres de jeux qui sont plus ou moins servis, comme par exemple : les jeux de rôles. Les RPG je crois qu'ils sont plutôt pas mal en terme de n'importe quoi.
Le combat en tour par tour par exemple. Pff, c'est quoi cette idée ?!
Combattant gauche : <<
-Tu m'attaque ?
-Ah non non non non, non c'est..c'est à ton tour. D'aileurs pendant que tu me pête la gueule, je vais...je vais lire un livre, hein c'est bien ça.
-Ok ! >>
Autre truc complétement débile dans les RPG, souvent pour avancer dans l'histoire tu dois aller de village en village tu vois, parler à des gens, rentrer dans leur maison...
D'où tu rentre dans les maisons des gens comme ça ?
Bonjour ! Je regarde juste hein,je fais un p'tit tour...
*siffle*
0:02:17,000 --> 0:01:25,000
Les jeux de baston aussi, ils sont pas mal dans le genre hein, y a un truc qui choque absolument personne : tu peux faire battre Ryu...contre Ryu. Tout va bien !
Attend Ten Ten Ten, Stop Stop Stop Stop Stop, tu me dis un truc...de...de visage. On a pas été dans la même classe par hasard ? En cours de latin ? En cours de poterie ? En cours de caring sur gazon ?
0:02:42,000 -- > 0:02:46,000
Je sais ce que vous dites, vous dites : "Ouais cyprien il critique, il propose rien etc."
Ok d'accord ok ! Je vais faire une proposition pour améliorer les jeux vidéos...
On arrête de laisser le choix le nom des personnages au joueurs.
Ca sert à rien, à part être méchant envers les personnages du jeu vidéo. C'est déjà pas mal !
Ah au faite, si vous rejoignez ma page facebook, je vous offre...
De l'amour.
Ah au faite n°2, ouais je numérote mes "ah au faite" pour mieux m'y retrouver, j'ai un nouveau blog : cyprien.fr
C'est parce-que c'est mon prénom. Si j'avais pris eu..."jeancharle.fr", non ça aurait pas de sens.